en plein coeur de la forêt montmorency
se déroule depuis quelques jours le
tournage du film
il pleuvait des oiseaux l'histoire
raconte la vie de trois vieux ermite
vivant dans le bois en abitibi pendant
que des incendies font rage
j'espère que ça va donner un film
absolument extraordinaire parce que le
roman quand je les lui jetons mais en
amour tout de suite avec ce roman qui
est absolument fabuleux son merveilleux
autour de nous et prennent soin nous ils
ont peur que je tombe qu'ils sont
toujours à prêt à me soutenir moi pas
chez l'aîné à 86 ans unis retourner en
pleine forêt je me trouve chanceux au
niveau cinématographique ont trouvé ça
très très beau et on trouvait qu'il y
avait une similitude ou si avec la forêt
en abitibi
j'ai des acteurs très généreux et qui
ont envie vraiment de vivre cette
aventure là pour l'amour du projet pour
avoir envie de partager cette histoire
là avec les spectateurs
j'avais vécu un peu la même chose sur le
déclin de l'empiré américain d'arc 1 on
n'était pas un mois confiné dans le même
temps à magog a lui même dans les mêmes
appartements et même vos pions p c'est
sûr que ça aide beaucoup à retrouver
cette atmosphère de deux solitudes
le conte doit avoir des personnages dans
ce film-là la décision de ces
personnages-là de de décider de son
allié 2010 de décider de sa vie et de sa
mort si jamais les choses dans le
programme hiver alors c'est un beau
projet
le tournage de il pleuvait des oiseaux
se terminera à la mi ou et sa sortie est
prévue à l'été 2010 neuf ici claudia gnl
radio canada
[Musique]